almost 30 years ago Back to the Future
Part 2 provided a glimpse of the future
that seemed funny and utterly
fantastical at the time but has actually
come true in a number of surprising ways
here's how Back to the Future accurately
predicted current events movie magic
while walking the streets of Hill Valley
in the future Marty gets a taste of some
futuristic advertising at the local
cinema while 3d movies and theaters have
actually been around since the 1950s the
trend didn't truly become a mainstream
standard option until James Cameron's
Avatar wowed audiences in 2009 since
then just about every new major release
has a 3d showing to go along with it of
course no matter how far we go with the
cinematic magic some folks will always
be disappointed shark still looks fake
can you see me now older Marty McFly
suffers the ultimate indignity when his
boss mr. Fujitsu fires him while he's at
home via video chat on his wall-mounted
video screen read my boss please no I
cannot be fired I'm fired that's not so
crazy today not only our flat wall hunk
TVs commonplace but employers can fire
their underlings via video all they want
with software like Skype and FaceTime
but then whatever points you give the
movie might be negated by its prediction
of a house filled with fax machines
total tekneqs
when Marty's kids sit down to dinner
wearing tech infused glasses it seemed
like a pretty good gag dad is for you
Google glass launched in 2013 and while
smart glasses haven't quite broken into
the mainstream yet gadget obsession
certainly has everyone's had dinner with
someone who can't stop playing with
their smartphones don't be this guy robo
reporters when Griff and his gang of
future flunkies get arrested a USA Today
drone snaps a picture while the majority
of today's journalists and photographers
are still actual human beings this was
surprisingly accurate these days drones
outfitted with cameras are becoming
pretty commonplace and growing more so
by the day it's only a matter of time
before enews has its own flying robotic
paparazzi to catch naked celebs garbage
gas when Doc goes back to 1985 to bring
Marty and Jennifer to the future he
needs to refuel the DeLorean but instead
of heading to his friendly neighborhood
plutonium repository he heads for the
garbage can instead but what are you
doing doc I need fuel quick get the car
we're still pretty far off from using
mr. fusion in place of nuclear materials
but a method for using trash as fuel has
actually found its way into some
countries when organic matter like
leftover food and biological waste
breaks down it releases methane carbon
dioxide and hydrogen all of that can be
combusted as fuel these days a few
countries in Europe have started
adopting this technology in fact Sweden
has had a biogas train since 2005 and in
2007 approximately 12,000 vehicles use
biogas fuel most of them in Europe it's
only a matter of time until we're all
taking a more active role in powering
our cars
flying Fords invariably whenever people
take a look at yesterday's movies
predicting tomorrow's technology they
always go back to one iconic moment Rose
we're going we don't need roads
like the volume
that's right we're still not all driving
flying cars but that doesn't mean we
can't since the mid-2000s a company
called Terrafugia has been working on
making flying cars a reality sure it
actually looks more like a fold-up plane
than a car that can fly but hey it's
street-legal all you got to do is figure
out how to fly the thing and if that has
you excited the company has plans for
more flying vehicles to hit the roads
and the skies in the next few years
meanwhile in September 2015 Toyota filed
a patent for a flying car of its own now
the companies are competing to make
flying cars a reality it's only a matter
of time before we complain about rush
hour from 30,000 feet hoverboards of
course if people aren't complaining
about not having flying cars that
probably means they're just complaining
about not having this the amazing and
entirely fictional hoverboard became an
instant sensation as soon as it appeared
and 80s and 90s kids have spent decades
demanding that science find a way to
catch up to this fantasy and while 2015
saw the popularization of dumb devices
called hoverboards that didn't actually
you know hover they're still hope in
August 2015 Lexus yes the car company
picked up the torch and created
hoverboard that actually hovers the
catch is that it needs a specifically
designed track and won't be
mass-produced as it was only created for
a commercial
then there's the startup arks PACs which
created the Hendo hoverboard while
videos of the ride show that the board
doesn't perform as well as the ones in
the movie it's enough for us to say that
hoverboards do in fact exist just don't
take it on the water
Cubs win yes in the 80s the thought of
the Cubs actually breaking their
decades-long World Series drought was
only slightly less absurd than them
actually doing so in the movies
futuristic setting the gag about the
Cubs finally taking the title in 2015
got a lot of laughs but it very nearly
came true in 2016 the Cubs won the World
Series in dramatic fashion taking game 7
into extra innings before squeaking out
a one-run victory over the Cleveland
Indians the fact that it all happened a
year after the movie predicted was noted
by none other than Michael J Fox who
added a couple of slacks when he
congratulated the team via Twitter
President Trump when Back to the Future
Part 2 was released businessman
Donald Trump had accrued a certain
measure of success but he was mostly
known to people in the New York area
most of them watched the movie without
ever suspecting that the future version
of Biff who uses his ill-gotten wealth
to build a casino empire that serves as
a springboard into political power was
based on the mogul in an interview with
The Daily Beast in 2015 the movies
writer Bob Gale explained his intentions
quote we thought about it when we made
the movie there's a scene where Marty
confronts Biff in his office and there's
a huge portrait of Biff on the wall
standing behind Biff and there's one
moment where Biff kind of stands up and
he takes exactly the same pose as the
portrait of course Gale wasn't totally
on point with his prediction Donald
Trump has yet to make out with
everybody's mom probably thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to